c'est l'image du jour maintenant au top
1 Jeremstar qui se fait interpeller par
la police devant le défilé Louis Vuitton
cet après-midi à Paris l'influenceur est
en train de militer contre
l'exploitation des animaux et de leur
peau lui-même habillé en serpent des PC
on était en serpent dépossés non ouais
on va le voir mais il est pas on peut
voir on va voir les trucs regarder les
bagues il arrive mais
[Musique]
ne doit plus y avoir de souffrance des
crocodiles sont tués dépecés vivants et
électrocuté pour vos sacs à main
s'il vous plaît
madame
non à la vie souffrante un petit peu
pour la meuf vous me faites pas
alors Jeremstar vous avez été vous avez
été vous en avez ils vous ont arrêté
embarquer au comico quoi comme ça on
serpent des PC ouais c'était la Gay
Pride dans le commissariat mais oui non
trêve de plaisanterie oui oui
effectivement les prévu de faire ça
ouais parce que quoi vous supportez pas
que des sacs à main soit fait avec des
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'effectivement
je fais des actions avec avec l'assaut
péta pour lutter justement quand la
maltraitance animale étant d'ailleurs
moi pas forcément parfait parce que par
le passé je n'avais absolument pas
conscience de ce que certains articles
de luxe finalement cachait et c'est
l'une des actions que que j'ai faite
c'est pas la première d'ailleurs mais
effectivement ça faisait un peu tâche
pour l'image de la marque et la police
est rapidement intervenue Emma embarquée
d'une manière effectivement qui a fait
pas mal le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
il y en a qui rêvaient de me voir en
prison mais c'est toujours pas le cas
d'ailleurs mais mais oui dans lâcher
direct bah oui on m'a même fait
on m'a dit qu'on était d'accord avec moi
les policiers d'ailleurs ont été
admirables c'est vrai qu'on leur tape
souvent dessus mais pour le coup le
combat était complètement compris et on
m'a même fait comprendre que j'avais le
droit de le refaire enfin il y a aucun
délit il y a pas eu de garde à vue il y
a juste eu un contrôle d'identité parce
que je n'en avais j'avais pas de pièce
d'identité sur moi mais non non il y a
pas du tout eu de garde à vue voilà moi
j'aime beaucoup jeremstar et j'aime
beaucoup pétards et les actions mais là
j'ai rien faire ce qui me gêne un peu
c'est que c'est vraiment de la provoc
pour la provoc quoi vous saviez que vous
alliez être arrêté vous saviez que ça
allait faire ça sauf que les personnes
qui font ça oui mais je trouve que c'est
presque c'est presque là pour l'image
que vous avez fait ça et je me demande
si au fond de vous vous réjouissez pas
de l'image qu'on voit derrière Cyril où
on vous prend par les bras et les jambes
parce que ça montre que l'action a été
dans votre esprit réussi voilà alors
évidemment qu'on fait des choses pour
qu'elle fonctionne et qu'elle fasse
parler j'étais ravi d'être arrêté et ça
n'était absolument pas prévu parce que
toutes les actions que j'ai faites il y
a jamais d'arrestation en général la
police vient il demande d'arrêter bon
évidemment quand ça m'est arrivé je
pense que mon petit problème était rien
par rapport à ces animaux qui sont
pendus vivants qui sont dépecés gonflés
d'eau et d'air pour faire des sacs à
main de [__] excusez-moi donc
franchement je n'étais rien du tout
donc on l'assume on l'assume moi il y a
une arrestation mais les policiers
étaient tout à fait sympathiques
et je vais même vous dire ça m'a même
plus ils étaient beaux garçons enfin il
y a aucun problème et oui évidemment que
plus on va pouvoir faire parler voilà
d'action voilà militante comme celle-ci
plus évidemment ça va servir et la
preuve je suis reçu aujourd'hui dans
l'émission parce que ça a fait scandale
et ça avait ça a fait parler si j'avais
fait un truc beaucoup plus calme tout le
monde s'en sera encore foutu la première
fois qu'on soit à serpent mais vous
pensez un serpent
tu aimes bien non mais oui
comme il dit et contrairement à
l'alimentation bah franchement je vais
te dire moi
je fais partie des connards qui ont
acheté des sacs pour des [__] et
pour des connards comme moi mais en fait
là je joue sur l'alimentation on est
sensibilisé sur le fait qu'on tue des
animaux pour les manger c'est vrai que
sur la mode quand on achète des
chaussures des sacs on n'a pas
conscience non et des animaux et donc en
ça je trouve que ce qu'il a fait et bien
et je trouve que on pourrait changer et
les marques doivent changer et j'ai été
aussi par des millions j'ai acheté
également enfin j'ai jamais acheté du
Louis enfin du pardon j'ai jamais acheté
de de marque de luxe tout ça parce que
ça jamais été mon truc mais c'est vrai
que je n'avais pas conscience de format
offert des sacs qu'on m'a offert des
choses et on ne se rend pas compte
vraiment moi j'ai vu des enquêtes avec
des images vraiment de ce qui se passe
de alors on a on est tous un petit peu
écœuré apeuré par un crocodile par un
serpent on se dit ah ben quelle horreur
c'est pas grave de toute façon c'est
animal est tellement ignoble pourtant
c'est un être juste qui éprouve la peur
s'il vous plaît est-ce que vous avez
déjà porté un polo Lacoste
sans doute mais j'ai déjà porté du cuir
aussi par le passé et d'ailleurs je la
cause il y a rien ici enfin c'est quoi
c'est du tissu après les débats sont
autres moi mon engagement c'est la cause
animale et pas que d'ailleurs mais oui
j'ai déjà aussi fait par le passé des
conneries je sais pas la cause en
l'occurrence mais non je ne suis pas
végétariennes avec la viande etc et je
pense aussi que c'est pour ça que PETA
fait régulièrement appel à moi parce que
je représente les gens imparfaits qui ne
se disent pas moi je suis le meilleur
alors qu'en fait c'est des gros
faux-culs et que dans le dos il y a
plein de conneries moi je ne suis pas
encore végétarien illégal c'est un peu
trop imparfait parce que quand on arrive
aussi militant c'est bizarre en même
temps tu vois mais grâce à ses actions
je m'éveille justement et de toute façon
je n'ai jamais vraiment mangé beaucoup
de viande
[Rires]
c'est pas parce qu'on est on n'est pas
végétarien qu'on a pas le droit de
passer des messages si mon influence
peut servir et éveiller voilà la
curiosité sur l'envers du décès de
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de la supposer
souffrance animale pardon de poser cette
question là mais est-ce qu'il y en a
vraiment une parce que là ça fait 5
minutes qu'on discute on part du
principe dans un instant jeremsar donc
voilà tu étais devant une grande marque
de luxe pour donc protester contre c'est
ça qui sont fait en python en alligator
en cuir
je voulais savoir qu'est-ce qu'on savait
exactement de la souffrance des animaux
sauvages puisque là on parle des animaux
sauvages on est d'accord là vous étiez
parliez essentiellement des serpents
des animaux voilà des pots exotiques
donc serpent alligators crocodile
qu'est-ce qu'on sait enfin à moins de
vivre dans une grotte on sait depuis la
nuit des temps que les animaux non mais
parce que vous dites
je vois pas tellement l'intérêt d'aller
tuer on a des enquêtes on a des enquêtes
qui sont sortis j'invite tout le monde
d'ailleurs à aller les voir des vidéos
alors moi j'ai du mal aussi aller
regarder à mes vidéos chocs qui sont
dans des fermes de crocodiles qui sont
détenus donc par ces grandes enseignes
dans des pays on a des vidéos où on voit
donc des serpents gonflés d'air et des
vidéos qui a éclatement on a des vraies
enquêtes de ça on a des crocodiles qui
sont pendus vivants et des PC vivants en
tout cas ce sont des images qui existent
qui ont été tournées via des personnes
qui ont infiltré ces lieux de production
donc ce sont des c'est réel Brigitte
Bardot à l'époque et la fourrure tout le
monde le découvrait mais pareil ça fait
depuis la nuit des temps que des animaux
souffrent et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
a quand même tout de quoi faire pour
pouvoir trouver des alternatives saines
sans faire souffrir des animaux encore
une fois pour des sacs de conasses mais
c'est vrai oui
je l'entends je la comprends moi j'ai
passé ça là bon voilà le luxe en produit
non je te jure j'ai pas un sac à dos je
sais non non la question que je vous
posez vous êtes là vous voulez faire
passer un message avec la puissance de
vos réseaux sociaux pourquoi vous êtes
venus tout seul
parce que je vous explique si jamais il
trouve pas par exemple c'est ça que dans
ces dans ces grandes marques avec une
traçabilité justement extrêmement rigide
extrêmement clair ils vont trouver au
marché noir avec des braconnages
complètement sauvages n'importe comment
donc au moins là vous savez que c'est
grandes marques par exemple elles sont
propriétaires de leur de leurs usine
donc déjà c'est une bonne chose parce
qu'il y a une traçabilité complète donc
c'est quand même mieux qu'un braconnage
complètement n'importe comment voyez son
mieux je pense pas parce qu'en plus de
ça c'est même pas du braconnage ça c'est
on élève les les animaux pour aller
faire souffrir en fait je pense que dans
le degré de la souffrance il y a pas à
savoir si ça vient de telle manière d'un
braconnage ou du SI ou de ça moi je
prends la parole sur un sujet qui me
touche et voilà je je prends
régulièrement la parole là-dessus et
finalement ça fonctionne non non je vous
laisse toucher c'est du plastique ah ça
va alors depuis j'ai déjà porté du cuir
par le passé parce que je n'avais
absolument aucune idée en tout cas je
peux vous garantir que je n'ai jamais eu
de serpent ni de crocodile c'est que
depuis que tu as pris conscience que il
se passait du malheur pour les animaux
dans le monde tu es devenu vegan au
niveau des vêtements mais l'alimentation
alors je ne suis pas vegan comme je le
dis dans les vêtements végétariens
évidemment maintenant il ne va pas venir
à l'idée d'aller acheter des pots animal
ou du chaussures en cuir des chaussures
en cuir j'en ai eu et j'en ai encore que
je ne mets pas et que j'ai encore mis il
y a encore moins d'un an mais je n'ai je
n'étais pas tombé sur ces vidéos donc
effectivement ça éveille et peut-être
qu'un jour à force d'être éveillé
également je vais finir par franchir le
cap et parvenir végétarien et vegan
là-dessus mais bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
en tout cas et tu vas faire d'autres
actions là oui je pense que j'en ferai
d'autres et je suis très fier et encore
une fois bah il y a pas d'incarcération
de garde à vue ou quoi on m'a même
presque encouragé au niveau de la police
à refaire ce genre de choses donc j'ai
envie de vous dire
crocodile cette semaine sur ces
bon merci Jérémy star fais gaffe quand
même de pas être un quart série tu as
déjà eu des punaises de lit
de punaise en face de moi mais oh là oh
et elles sont nocives celle-ci allez on
va passer l'histoire du jour on va
parler de ce fléau dont tout le monde
parle en ce moment